how's the compress Wow check septic I
played this game and I'm like please
this is a Swedish game I'm Swedish Jack
I hope you're watching I'll show you how
it's done when you play IKEA simulator
or whatever the [ __ ] this is
so this is basically a game about
building furniture that you get from a
care I wish people can't build furniture
everyone knows this everyone so I'm just
gonna go ahead and start here we have a
Buick Burke uh which doesn't mean [ __ ] I
like how it's the color of the swedish
blank beautiful it makes me proud to be
an american swedish swedish it might
pray I like the duck paintings we really
do know Fine Art in Sweden let's build
this table I [ __ ] lava tables
especially tables from Ikea
quality and perfection like anything
from Sweden including myself boom it's
right in it just sucks in just like
anything from Sweden we just suck it in
[ __ ] with me right now table you best
not be [ __ ] with me table man I care
it's just my Lord and Savior have you
tried the meatballs they're they're the
best meatballs you'll ever have they're
filled with horse meat apparently
kolinsky
my favorite lamp this is a classic lamp
Jesus Christ uh all right so we got the
page I am all about that base shut up so
here's the thing about Ikea if you look
up the manual you're basically a [ __ ]
ass [ __ ] and you might as well kill
kill your hamster if you have one um
dammit I know this I know this don't
think that I don't know this is I'm
going with my Swedish intuition here if
you can't we we actually teach IKEA in
school school in Sweden where the [ __ ]
yes I mean of course of course
see you think I don't you think I'm not
Swedish like don't talk to me unless
you're Swedish please there it is suck
it in boy so [ __ ] good so [ __ ] go
look at this lamp look at this Swedish
perfection stop look at I didn't mean my
face I meant the lamb Jesus Christ this
is probably game of the year every year
in Sweden this is probably the greatest
piece of art that it's ever been created
to if you don't like this game than you
hate art and that's your problem I
really think they should just make me
the president of Sweden no lamp lap lap
Jesus Christ lamp all right this must be
some fake IKEA [ __ ] cos limes limes does
not do that I swear to God
[ __ ] just stand up the [ __ ] is
wrong with you
I swear to God suck it up whoa Jesus
Christ Lord
did he just say [ __ ] Lord I'm pretty sure
the game just called me a [ __ ] Lord so
what's ironic about this game is that
you can play with four other people
which is weird because Swedish people
don't have friends so I don't see how
much see you get Orrin you get art when
you don't use the manual do you think
the Mona Lisa was made through a manual
no do you think the Last Supper was made
from a manual no any classic work of art
was made from pure heart I was way more
inspiring than I thought it would be
Jesus Christ this is a chair like what
the [ __ ] assist
shut up chair you don't have feelings
okay so we having a table or we have
another land why would I why would I
build another one you [ __ ] high do I
look like an Ikea factory to you this
game is [ __ ] offensive just cuz I'm
Swedish
some people may say you shouldn't put
your table on the table and to those I
say look at that [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
beautiful
just don't let me build another [ __ ]
night I swear to god Lord shut up the
[ __ ] gluten glue it was a table another
[ __ ] table is it not how you IKEA all
right
just [ __ ] not how you IKEA all right
well let's you know what you know what
they say if you can't build a table
build a house so a lot of people say
tables have four legs
but I say tables have one leg and you
guys don't know how art works that's why
they call it artwork because you don't
know how it works so this is pretty much
the standard Swedish home I would say
look at that how many [ __ ] tables is
a man need so there there's my table
right there I'm so glad I didn't follow
the instructions because it could have
gone crazy easy but I just finished the
game did I just beat the IKEA simulator
oh my god I wish all my hair is watching
this [ __ ] I hope you learned something
here today because this is pretty much
all I know about life IKEA and Abba iPod
will be another episode thanking us for
watching as always stay awesome bros
what are we going Taylor what are you
doing
Oh God they see her Taylor Taylor Dow oh
that burns
that was close one oh my god the cops
are after Taylor